[Applause]
thank you so much I'm delighted to be
here I can't think of anywhere I would
rather be on a Saturday night then in a
library with a bunch of book lovers so
I'm delighted that you're all here and
I'm particularly jazzed to be in Madison
home of the mustard museum so it's
wonderful to be here as has been
mentioned I am one of the co-authors of
apps obscura which came out in book form
a few weeks ago just to give you a bit
of background on how apps obscura began
and what it's all about it started as a
website in 2009 as a collaboration
between my two co-authors Joshua 4 and
Dylan Soros and the goal was to assemble
a database of places that inspire wonder
that are fantastic and magical but that
you might not know about unless someone
in the know had tipped you off the
hidden wonders of the world
and to give you an example of what might
constitute a hidden wonder the Eiffel
Tower is not a hidden wonder but the
secret apartment near the top of the
Eiffel Tower
that Gustave Eiffel built to impress his
friends that Thomas Edison visited that
has nice carpeting in a grand piano that
is a hidden wonder and those are the
types of things that we are looking for
in ours obscura so this website began
seven years ago now and Josh and Dylan
started assembling these places they
opened it up to the public to people
around the world and said show us what
you've got and they weren't quite sure
what to expect they weren't quite sure
how many submissions they would receive
if people would really understand the
whole hidden wonder thing we're now up
to 10,000 places so it's it's taken off
somewhat and people seem to get it
people get the hidden wonder thing we
get so many submissions from people who
remember something from their childhood
Oh down the road
that was that guy who built that castle
I wonder if it's still there and there's
this real sense of hometown pride people
showing off the things that they've
discovered and that's what we're
cultivating so as a way of showing you
some examples of what is inside this
book because we've collected about 700
we've done a sort of greatest hits album
a sampler platter of the places that
we've collected for the website I just
wanted to take you on a quick world tour
that showcases a few of the places in
the book so let's get started all right
so this is one of the first places that
was submitted to the website within the
first few months of it launching and it
was submitted by someone who lives in
Chariton G in the north of India and
this is one of the wettest most humid
regions in the world and one of the
problems with creating infrastructure in
such a place is that it disintegrates
pretty quickly Wood rots metal rusts so
in shareable energy some of the people
there have come up with a very ingenious
and visually stunning solution to this
problem these are the route bridges of
Terra punji and they there are a few of
them but this one in particular is
especially spectacular because it's a
double-decker one but the way that
they're made is that the villages build
a trestle over the river and then they
guide the aerial roots of these trees
across those trestles it takes about 15
years for the bridge to grow and it can
continue growing for centuries so when
we receive this we thought okay yeah
this could work this is incredible
and it's real to continue with the theme
of bridges this is also a bridge it's a
land bridge that unites the islands in
South Korea of jindo and Mota
but this bridge only appears for about
an hour or so twice a year and there is
some mythology associated with this
bridge it involves what is basically the
South Korean equivalent of Moses and the
story goes that a tiger had descended
upon the island of Jindo and everybody
managed to escape apart from this
elderly woman and the tiger was menacing
and encroaching upon her and she looked
at it and thought not on my watch so she
prayed for a bridge to open up for the
waters to recede so that she might
safely escape to the island of murder
and low according to the mythology this
did happen so every year once in May and
once in June this bridge opens up and
the people from Jindo and moto and
visitors if you want to go and join the
fun walk from their separate islands
along the bridge meet in the middle and
then turn around and go back home this
is a fascinating place it's about a
hundred miles north of Los Angeles and
in 1958 an eccentric
urban planner by the name of NAT
Mendelsohn purchased about 80,000 acres
in the Mojave Desert and he had a grand
plan the turn was to establish this
giant sprawling automobile based
metropolis that would rival la that
would be this utopia so he brought up
this land he laid out all the streets he
gave every street a name and that's
about as far as the project got because
he clearly vastly overestimated people's
willingness to move out to the Mojave
Desert and and established a utopian
metropolis that sort of a shame for him
but
this still exists the all these roads
that have been named are still there and
we have events real world events where
we go out and explore we have different
obscura societies in various chapters
around the US and a few years ago we we
organized this convoy of people to go
out to these streets in what was going
to be called California City and they
went exploring they walked along these
streets that are now being reclaimed by
the sand I've not been there yet but I
very much want to it looks from from the
air it looks like a giant circuit board
it's incredible this is like the
greatest hit of the greatest hit this is
a classic this is the result of an
industrial accident essentially this is
in the Turkmenistan desert it's referred
to locally as the gates of Hell or the
door to hell in 1971 a Soviet team of
Soviet geologists were drilling for
natural gas in the Turkmenistan desert
as you do and they found some
unfortunately this gas was located in a
giant subterranean cavern and as they
began drilling this hole opened up and
their drilling rigs fell in and so they
reacted perhaps slightly panicked driven
by setting the whole thing on fire and I
suppose the mentality was give it a few
days maybe a few weeks this thing will
burn off it'll be fine
45 years later it's still burning and
these gates of Hell are 200 feet wide
you can go and visit them as this this
brave chap on the left here is yeah this
man in these another subterranean cavern
slightly less hazardous his name is raw
Paulette and
he is one of many creative driven
visionaries many of whom a rather
eccentric that we celebrate in the Atlas
there is a former monk in Madrid named
dong gusto who woke up one morning and
decided that he had to hand build a
cathedral for the next 50 years of his
life he's still doing it Rob Paulette is
somewhat similar but he uses the medium
of sand and since the 1990s he has been
walking out in teams New Mexico desert
and digging these incredible caves
he takes commissions but it's not really
about that it's about him expressing
himself through the way that he digs he
put the wheelbarrow on his back carry
the shovel and he just listens to the
muse and he's made about a dozen of
these caves since 1992 ah all right
this fellow who looks rather the worse
for wear but not when you consider that
one he died in 1783 and two it was at
the age of 96 and three he mummified
himself
his name was shin yokai Shonen and he
was one of many monks in northern Japan
who are part of the shugendo variant of
Buddhism which which also throws a bit
of Taoism and Shinto into the mix and
for a few centuries these monks of
northern Japan were engaged in the art
of self-mummification it's called the
suction butsu of japan and you might be
thinking well I studied ancient Egypt in
school I know how to mummifies someone
else in theory once they're dead you do
the old
hook up the nostril heads in the cranial
cavity type procedure but how do you
mummify yourself surely that's
impossible
close to impossible but as you can see
it happened it was a 10-year process and
it began with a very strict diet that
was undertaken for a thousand days it
was basically nuts and seeds and a lot
of exercise because the idea was to
strip your body of fat in this initial
stage once that was done you didn't
really get a respite diet wise it just
became more strict the next stage was to
feast upon bark and the sap from the
Urushi tree which is ordinarily used to
lack of wood so the idea behind that is
you lacquer your internal organs it's
just that easy
once this stage was complete the monks
were generally very close to death so
what they did was they went into a tomb
they sat in the lotus position and they
chanted mantras and every day they would
ring a bell to signal that they were yet
living and when the bell stopped ringing
the tomb was sealed after they had been
left there for a while the monk would be
retrieved and put on display and
venerated several hundred monks
attempted this procedure about two dozen
succeeded and they're about 16 that are
still on display in northern Japan the
practice was actually outlawed at the
end of the 19th century by the Meiji
Emperor who I imagine was pretty much
like guys come on we need some limits
here this is a charming sort of local
mystery that is a lot closer to homes in
Minnesota on the north shore of Lake
Superior close to the Canadian border
and this is called Devil's kettle and as
you can see it's a waterfall that splits
into two and on the right side the
waterfall keeps going on the left side
the water goes into this what is known
as the devil's kettle and emerges no one
knows where and it's not for lack of
trying people have tried to solve this
mystery they've thrown thousands of ping
pongs in ping pong balls in there
they've tried to dye the water they've
thrown GPS devices in there nothing has
yet yielded an explanation there's just
a fun local mystery try to solve it if
you wanted journey to Minnesota
this looks like an idyllic place to go
perhaps on a pleasure cruise like some
vintage postcard here I would not
recommend going there however and the
reason why is in the name of this place
it's called snake island it's true I
like that murmur in the crowd were
indeed warranted this place is off the
coast of South Paulo in Brazil and it is
named snake island because it is home to
a vast quantity of golden lancehead
Viper z-- they are endemic to this
island they exist only on this island
and given half the chance so they will
kill you their venom is not a good time
I don't kill you they'll cause a lot of
damage but what is remarkable that this
island is the density of the snakes
estimates have varied over the years but
rough guide there's about one snake per
square meter
I'm from the Commonwealth I work in
metric but if you don't all you have to
remember is that on snake island you're
never more than about three feet from
potential death
also one handy little tidbit the snakes
are not just terrestrial they're also
arboreal so you might be walking along
and feel one drop right beside your fees
which is terrifying you're not actually
allowed to go to snake island you have
to convince the Brazilian Navy that you
have a legitimate scientific reason to
visit so if it sounds enticing start
thinking of some reasons so in Florence
the museum that everybody wants to go to
is the afid sea it's the home of the
Birth of Venus a bunch of Botticelli
artworks because Michelangelo in theirs
and da Vinci but the lines get really
long particularly in summer you can be
waiting for hours to even get inside
there's a museum around the corner from
the effete sea that is less visited it's
a science museum and among all the
scientific instruments the globe's
sections you will find Galileo's middle
finger classic his finger was swiped
from his corpse about a hundred years
after his death while it was being moved
it's been in various places since then
but since 1927 it has been at this
Museum which was recently renamed the
Galileo Museum and there are various
ways to interpret this object
I mean Galileo had a complicated
relationship with the church you can see
it as he is merely indicating the
heavens above or you can view it as a
more pointed message the interpretation
is up to you
so there was a period of a few decades
in between when aircraft started to be
used as part of military weapons and
prior to the development of radar for
detecting an incoming bombing raid and
during this period there were some
ingenious creative approaches for how to
know when you're about to be attacked
these three concrete objects are on the
south coast of England and they're known
as listening ears because what the
British did was to build these curves
these little parabolas these nautical
and semicircles as a means of trying to
amplify incoming aircraft noise they
built them they pointed them toward
Germany and they hoped for the best you
can see on the right here there's a I'd
see that but there's a stand where a
microphone would have been mounted so
the idea was to amplify the sound that
the microphone picked up a guy with a
device that was sort of like a
stethoscope it has these had these big
tubes here that United here would also
sit there and listen really hard they
sort of work
ish nowhere near as well as radar these
were established well devices like these
were built in the 1920s 1930s but as
aircraft moved faster the benefits
became negligible they would probably
give you an ever so slight edge if the
Luftwaffe was about to attack but not a
lot of time to prepare
this is the peshwa Chaka also known as
the last Incan rope bridge and bridges
like these which are woven from the
grass that you see on the bottom right
used to be all over the Andes but as far
as we've been able to tell this is the
last one and it spans a valley in Peru
that the guy on the bridge is actually
my one of my co-authors Josh and what
happens in what makes it so special
is every year because the bridge is used
so much it starts to sag starts to look
a little bit dicey for walking upon so
the villagers come together they cut
down the existing bridge let it fall
into the valley sometimes burn it if
they're feeling dramatic and they weave
another one's the villages bring all
these grasses together and they weave
them they plat them they plat them again
and they reestablish this rope bridge so
this is the last surviving one of what
used to be a whole network this just
looks like a kind of old-school judge
organ in a cave which sure has its
merits in terms of strange and wondrous
but you're not seeing the whole picture
here these are the cave in the Luray
Caverns in virginia and this instrument
is there because of a man with an
incredible name
leyland sprinkle who in the 1950s went
spelunking in Luray Caverns and decided
that they would make the perfect
backdrop for what would become the
world's largest musical instrument what
you see here is the core of it this
console but what you don't see are the
pipes of this church organ the pipes are
actually stalactite
and what he did was spend years
searching these caves for stalactites
that would make the exact right sound
when you struck them so once we had
found them he wired five miles where the
cables from this central console to each
individual stalactite it's called the
static pipe organ and Leyland's mr.
sprinkle used to play the organ
it is now played it's played in an
automated way but CDs with music from
the salic pipe organ are still on sale
at the gift shop in the caverns I
believe they're marketed as musical gems
from solid rock this wonderful device
which resembles a tiny carousel is
actually an attempt at a weather
prediction device it was first exhibited
at the 1851 London Exhibition it was
created by a man with another great name
a name perfect for meteorology dr.
George Merryweather and dr. Merryweather
who was a surgeon had come to decide or
perhaps imagine that when there was an
approaching storm freshwater leeches
seemed to get a little agitated so he
thought how can i harness with
meteorology wise and what he did was he
built a device called the tempest
prognosticator which is the very device
you see before you and how it worked was
there's this circle of little jars into
which a freshwater leech would be placed
in each one the jaws would be connected
by little wires to bells it's eerily
similar to the self mummified monks now
that I think about it but the idea was
that if a storm were approaching these
leeches would
and the little ropes would jangle and
the bells would ring and you would think
ha
better take the washing in it did not so
much work which is why we have
thermometers and barometers other than
instead of tempest prognosticators which
is a little bit sad because look at this
thing but there is still a model in a
museum that is exactly the kind of
museum that we love to celebrate at
atlas obscura
it's called barometer world it's in the
north of England and it's all about
barometers go if you can alright this is
a place that I first went to as a child
and as such it's made it indelible mark
on my brain and soul
it looks like fantasy but it resembles a
nebula or a galaxy if you don't know
what it is but each of these little
glowing lights is in fact a fungus gnat
in its larval stage so the story is
these are the white Homer caves in New
Zealand on the North Island which is
where I was born and what you do is
there's a big network of caves you go in
there and be the final moment of wonder
is that you get in this boat that rows
along a subterranean River and you can
close your eyes very dark and all of a
sudden this feeling of what looks like a
universe opens up before you all these
amazing little glowing things and they
are fungus nuts
they are bio luminescent fungus nets
they don't last in this stage for very
long but there are thousands and
millions of them and we allow obscura
adorn bioluminescence this is but but
one of the bioluminescent places in the
book there's also the if you've been to
the Smoky Mountains at the right time of
year you get these synchronised
fireflies the same thing happens
in part of Malaysia and into Yama Bay in
Japan there are the Firefly squid that
light up the Bay those sorts of things
so this is a particularly magical
example of bioluminescence another
another place from my part of the world
so I was born in New Zealand but I grew
up in Australia and this is near my
negative woods it's off the south coast
southeast coast of Australia it's a
volcanic Schad shard goes by I don't you
get confused sometimes they don't know
what I'm saying
what kind of spire and it's about 1,800
feet tall it's known as bald pyramid and
its significance comes from in 2001 two
scientists were scaling these
treacherous sides because they were
looking for a creature that the world
had given up on the creature is known by
many names some call it the walking
sausage it's name is more scientifically
the Lord Howe Island stick insect and it
looks like a stick insect but it's the
size of your palm so if you want to see
it look at it
just imagine that but this big so these
scientists in 2001 had gotten a tip from
some climbers that they had found the
remains of these insects that had long
been thought extinct they used to exist
on Lord Howe Island which is about 13
miles from this spire and when black
rats were introduced to the island in
1918 they began to disappear and by 1930
they were thought all extinct but
because the the walking sausage bodies
had been discovered by climbers on this
fire there was reason to go and search
and in 2001 these two scientists they
were about 225 feet up the spire and
they found this little nest of about two
dozen walking sausages and having made
this discovery the next thing to ask
themselves was what do we do with them
it's such a small fragile population of
a creature that was thought extinct so
they spent about two years trying to
puzzle out what to do with these
creatures and in 2003 they decided to
take two pairs to the Melbourne Zoo to
try to get the population going again
unfortunately one of the pairs died but
the second pair became the basis for
what is now a thousand strong walking
sausage population at the relevant zoo
and their names were Adam and Eve oh
this one's disturbing okay
neck repents we have some fans in the
audience oh I'm so glad I'm so glad yes
the infamy precedes them so okay this
object is located at the Museum the
Icelandic Museum of witchcraft and
sorcery which is a few hours outside
Reykjavik go it's a good time this is a
replica garment but according to the
curators there who may be having us all
on these actually existed in the 17th
century they are called the necro pants
and the story goes as follows
so the procedure of the necro pads which
are intended to bring you luck and
wealth begins with a simple request you
approach a friend who is male ideally a
friend an acquaintance would be an
awkward conversation and you say when
you die may I have your skin only from
the waist down let's not be unreasonable
ideally this person would say yes and
you would wait for them to die or become
involved somehow but not ask questions
and exhume their court slay the skin
from the waist down ensuring to keep it
all in one piece and then Don the skin
pants yourself as a pair of trousers
next comes the part of the procedure
that I find a little unreasonable you're
supposed to steal a coin from a poor
widow which seems excessive not sure why
she has to already be poverty-stricken
but you snatch that coin you place it in
the scrotal pockets of the Necker
advance and the idea is that that coin
in the groin will attract more coins
that it will bring you luck and wealth
and once once the yes I heard rumors of
virtual void once the scrotal pocket is
replete with coins or it begins to chafe
whichever comes first you pass the necro
pants on to the next lucky rare wearer
and for good luck you are supposed to do
it one leg at a time just like an
amusing three-legged race situation we
have not been able to confirm the
veracity of these necro pants reports
but we thought the story was so good
that we had to include it so you're
welcome
these are the doctor Falls
and they are located just outside a
village in Peru called coca chamber and
until 2005
nobody beyond the people in this village
knew of their existence and in 2005 a
German Explorer tourist traveler was
venturing in this area area and saw
these Falls and thought they're really
tall Falls like really tall like top 10
in the world tall and he spoke to their
villages and the villages sort of said
well yeah we know that they're tall but
there are so many things out there in
the world you know there are so many
waterfalls we just kind of got used to
them and when these waterfalls were
measured it became apparent that so
there are different ways of measuring
waterfalls it's a bit of a cause of
controversy
I found out courtesy of the internet but
by some measure these Falls are the
third tallest in the world they're over
2500 feet tall and my co-authors Dylan
and Josh visited the Falls about five
years ago and when they spoke to the
people of Kruger timber it was really
fascinating what they said you know they
reiterated these points about well yes
we knew that the Falls were incredible
I guess but we were just so accustomed
to them you know we sort of forgot that
they were there and this is something
that we see a lot that it's sort of part
of the core philosophy a touts obscura
which is there are incredible things all
around us you don't have to go to Peru
you don't have to go see the necro pants
and Iceland to to happen upon something
strange and wondrous an extraordinary
there are things in our own backyard
that are incredible and it's just a
matter of opening your eyes and and not
becoming
complacent about what's around here so
to that end I wanted to talk about one
more place very briefly which is right
here in the wonderful state of Wisconsin
it is dr. Evan Boggs forevertron and how
many of you have been to talk to
everyone for ever drawing yes so this is
what I was talking about earlier about
hometown pride about wanting to share
the special things that you've found
that are in your neighborhood with the
world because dr. Evan was forevertron
is incredible it was created in the
1980s by a retired wrecking and salvage
expert Tom every who as he built this
developed his own alter-ego as Doctor
evermore the idea of this pewter
Victorian space machine is that he will
blast into the heavens on a lightning
beam in this egg's it's at the top here
and this is right here it's just just
north of Madison off highway 12 so these
are the kinds of places that we love to
celebrate we would love for you all to
go out there and explore see what's in
your neighborhood see what's in your
state share them with us in the world
and and be an explorer so and we hope
that we use that you use Out's Explorer
as your guide so that's about it for my
formal presentation part of the
proceedings I would love to take
questions if you have any
my only disclaimer is if you ask me
about a specific detail in one of the
700 places in the book I may not
immediately remember it but that's only
because there were 700 cases in the book
but I will try my very best
so does anyone have any questions
oh and that there's a microphone in the
center I'll give you time to go to the
microphone you want to see the neck
repents again
so I gather that started as a website
and I would imagine that the book is
constantly in need of updating do you
anticipate future additions yes
definitely and not just for that reason
I mean we would definitely want to put
future updated versions of this specific
book out into the world but we're also
already looking at what other books can
rewrite because condensing the world
wonders into 480 pages is very very
difficult we're looking at putting out
books that are a little bit more
specific in their focus whether that's
geographically or by subject matter if
you look at the index in our book it's
things like treacherous paths and
mummified remains and any one of those
categories could be an entire book unto
itself our editor at workman got a
little gave us some feedback about the
fact that we had too many anatomical
museums that featured wax models of
dermatological diseases so we can easily
put 40 of those in a book but yes we we
would love to put future editions
updated editions of this book but also
other books out into the world thank you
I also wanted to say that well doctor
evermore site is a great example of what
what you're investigating around the
world Wisconsin is full of those places
and and I'd is any number of other
candidates I don't know if you've got
other examples in the book but we have
we have a lot on the website one in the
book which I'm all of you probably
familiar with is housed on the rock
where do another one of those ones that
you all of course know about but people
around the world don't so it is yeah
it's something that's worth sharing with
the world and I hope you don't mind
sharing is a precious place like that
this painted forest and Fred Smith's
concrete park and Dickeyville grotto and
any number thank you for doing this
thank you
this is for tall people um we're
actually going to New Zealand for the
first time and uh what would you
recommend or do I should I just buy the
book that would be the main version
there are so many things says if you go
to kpop a museum which is in Wellington
where I was born you will see a giant
squid that has been beautiful a colossal
squid in fact that has been beautifully
monitored that's a great place to go to
have a museum in general is wonderful
what else is in the book there's if you
go to Rotorua just roll the bubbling mud
and lovers there's a thing called
craters of the moon which is wonderful
to walk around it is sort of lunar
landscape it's very strange and then you
have places like if you want to note it
up if and if you're interested in the
economy there's there's a machine called
the ammoniac machine which uses water to
demonstrate how the economy works which
is I think it's at the University of
Otago it's in the book but yet that I
would definitely recommend the white
timer glowworm caves
that's a magical experience that would
be topping my with where is the
University of a taco it's in it's on the
South Islands I should really know this
Dunedin yeah thank you okay Danny thank
you okay
was there a wonder that you wanted in
the book that didn't make the cut there
were so many the problem with narrowing
down we started out with this giant
spreadsheet we really tried to have a
balance in terms of geography and the
types of places and the problem was we
all had three of us had certain
predilections and certain things that we
adored not all of which made it into the
book one as I was talking about before
we really loved medical museums it's a
thing that we all like um and when the
problems with that was like some of them
are quite similar to each other
das Pecola and these places that by
themselves like viewed alone are so
incredible but when you already have one
that's very similar in the book huh we
got to take one out but I really want to
keep it so I would say yes medical
museums generally and Accio Ares bone
churches we tried not to make the book
to defi raise up there's a little death
in there but death is treated in various
interesting ways
things like coffins that look like
tigers the merry cemetery which is a
great laughs thank you thank you
No
so question is how many places I or with
the author's have gone to we have we've
been to as many places as possible that
I in the book we're up to
we started there's a waiter on the
website to log places that you've been
to and we each got up to about a hundred
and then sort of stopped counting but
the book is very much a crowd-sourced
project we definitely we definitely rely
on our wonderful community of Alice's
obscure explorers who are out there
finding things for us so we've been to
as many places as time and budget would
allow we did do as much in person
fact-checking as possible I did go to
the salt cathedral and lick the wall it
does taste like salt but yes this is
very much a collaborative project
another question coming up build the
suspense
two quick questions on one is do you
often get asked by people not to put
stuff up because they don't want people
to know about it they want it to be
their own secret and then secondly were
there issues or have there been issues
about cultural sensitivity people being
concerned about you sort of maybe making
light of something that they see as a
very smoky spiritual place good
questions so first question is about
people maybe not wanting places to be
included in the book that's definitely a
big concern of ours we don't want to
over expose a place or make people
annoyed by the fact that they suddenly
have a line of people out the door with
what was previously a special small
place we have found thus far I think
without exception that the places we've
highlighted our places that in some
cases were struggling to survive and
bringing attention to them and sending
visitors to them has been a good thing
that's been our experience so far but
it's definitely a concern of ours that
you know it is a bit strange to be
called atlas obscura and then if the
book does well then maybe these places
won't be so obscure I mean places like
the glowworm caves people in New Zealand
know about we don't so much know about
so sometimes it's a it's a case of
spotlighting places that are only known
locally and bringing in more people from
outside so that they know about it yeah
in general that that is a concern about
and we I mean if someone asked us to
take place off our website we definitely
would but that hasn't happened so far in
terms of cultural sensitivity absolutely
again this is a big concern of ours when
putting the book together we never want
to point to something and say that's
weird what's with these people doing
this thing we include things in the book
because we want to celebrate them and we
want to show we want to give a sense of
what's out there in the world you know
the one of the prime reasons for us
doing this is to say
people see the world you know what
what perspectives can we view this from
and so that was definitely something
that we thought about when you know in
terms of the language we were using in
terms of the tone speaking to people who
are part of these groups or who owned
these museums I'm not trying to
represent them without talking to them
yeah and I mean even the the concept of
exploration and discovery is a little
bit loaded it's you know it's kind of
the images of some white guy internships
or like the even the the phrase cabinet
of curiosities or you know the grand
European tour it's like cash Doug white
guy going and taking stuff and bringing
it back we want to move beyond that we
see exploration and discovery as
something that is open to all something
that doesn't require money or status or
for you to be a particular type of
person so it's more about the mentality
of it the philosophy of it we want it to
be accessible to all
[Applause]